blizzard gives a big crucial update on
the messy OverWatch 2 launch a bevy of
new Pokemon scarlet and violet details
and the new Need for Speed looks good
all this on today's Gamespot news
Blizzard's long awaited OverWatch 2
arrived this week but the launch didn't
exactly go to plan blizzard has
apologized for the launch issues saying
it failed to meet the expectations of
players and blizzard itself the studio
also announced it is removing the phone
registration requirement for many and
provided an update on what's being done
to mitigate server issues to help
players get into matches the list of
known issues for OverWatch 2 currently
stands at nearly 15 000 but there are a
few key issues that blizzard wanted to
address right now the first off of which
is the phone number requirement blizzard
initially said the phone number
requirement was part of an effort to
combat cheating but many people
complained about it for a variety of
reasons and some prepaid phone plans did
not work while most users will no longer
be required to provide a phone number
accounts not connected to Battlenet and
new accounts must still provide one
regarding stability blizzard just
recently released a patch for the login
experience that has already been shown
to increase the reliability of logging
in blizzard is now working on another
server update to help reduce how often
players become disconnected when they
can manage to connect to a game players
have also reported that they are logging
in to OverWatch 2 only to see that some
or all of their items and data are
missing the good news is that no items
or progress has been lost blizzard said
this issue comes from players not
completing their account merge process
another factor is that items are taking
time to populate from the original
OverWatch to OverWatch 2. quote in all
cases no player data has been wiped or
lost we have a client-side fix for this
that cannot be deployed until next week
so we are exploring server side fixes
and will provide updates as more
information becomes available blizzard
said blizzard went on to say that anyone
who has unlocked hero but that hero is
still showing as locked should log back
into the game and this will resolve the
issue quote in most cases players can
open a support ticket if they are still
experiencing problems finally blizzard
said all of OverWatch 2's launch issues
were exacerbated by the DDOS attacks
against the game quote while they did
not directly cause any of these issues
they made the environment in which we
work on these issues more challenging we
have not suffered any further attacks
blizzard said blizzard is not just the
name of a massive video game developer
but also the name of a move in Pokemon
which just revealed in a new trailer for
the upcoming scarlet and violet titles
that players will be able to craft their
own TMS using resources dropped from
Pokemon that have been caught or
defeated in battle the Pokemon company
didn't go too deep into how many TMS can
be crafted or how to unlock recipes but
from the video shown off it looks like
you can create TMS based on classic
Pokemon abilities using League points
berries and other materials the rest of
the video showed off more of the
customization you'll be able to
experiment with giraffarig's new
Evolution that transforms it into
ferragraph for rigor photograph and a
sandwich-making activity I'm dead
serious check out the full 15 minute
trailer here on gamespot's YouTube
another game that got a ton of details
today is Need for Speed Unbound as
rumored the game appears to feature
anime elements that certainly make it
stand out from past entries players will
try to win the grand which is described
as the quote ultimate street racing
challenge in the game's world of
Lakeshore in the campaign players will
collect and customize new cars as they
make their way to the top EA's Criterion
Studio known for its work on the burnout
series is developing Need for Speed
Unbound the game is set to release on
December 2nd across Xbox series X and S
PS5 and PC you can also check out that
trailer on our YouTube as well and that
is it for today's Gamespot news what do
you think of Blizzard's response to all
the OverWatch 2 issues are you excited
for the new Need for Speed and how about
those updates for Pokemon Scarlets and
violet let us know in the comments below
and we will see you here tomorrow for
more Gamespot news
[Music]
oh